hey this is pressure Locker the average
age of a family consisting of two
parents and their children is 20 if we
exclude one parent who is 40 the average
age drops to 15 how many children are in
the family can you figure it out give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for the solution
so while this is a straightforward
algebra problem many people do not get
the correct answer some people
incorrectly solve for the total number
of people in the family and forget to
exclude the two parents and other people
do not set up the equations correctly
because they forget there are two
parents to calculate so we are going to
solve this problem and make sure we
solve for the total number of children
we'll set a variable C to equal what we
want the number of children in the
family
well then denote a variable X to equal
the sum of everyone's ages this is the
sum of the two parents ages plus the sum
of all the children now let's translate
the word information into equation we
have the average age of the family equal
to 20 now this numerator will be the sum
of everyone ages X the denominator will
be the two parents plus the children so
this will be C plus 2 and we want X
divided by C plus 2 to equal the average
20 the next condition is if we exclude
one parent age 40 the average drops to
15 so from this fraction we're going to
remove 40 from the numerator and we're
going to remove one observation one
individual from the denominator so we
get X minus 40 divided by C plus one
equal the average of 15 so we now have a
system of equations which we can solve
we'll solve each equation for the very
act we now have two expression for the
variable act so we can set these two
expressions equal to each other we can
now solve this equation for the single
variable C we get the answer that C
equals three there are three children in
this family did you figure it out thanks
for watching this video please subscribe
to my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch from my blog
mind your decisions you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at Prashar ker
and if you liked this video please check
out my book there are links in the video
description